alright it's finally here we're doing
our second ever Reuben report fan show
so a month ago I asked our fans once
again to let me know why I should
interview you and I got to tell you guys
you did not disappoint we received about
3,000 responses and ended up selecting
20 of you which believe me was not easy
to do your passion diversity of thought
and commitment to free speech is
absolutely inspiring and gives me the
fuel I need to do what I do we did our
best to take an eclectic mix of people
from all over the world and I think
you're going to really dig the group of
people that we chose to interview today
for the bank if I had to click myself oh
noes spectrum I'm a little bit to the
right of the tilde hunt you wrote I am a
gay mixed race white flash Latino
transvestite Trump supporter gender
identity is is who you feel you are and
sexual orientation is who you like to
get naked with on a personal note I just
want to say how truly odd and humbled I
am by your submissions the fact that you
watch this show that you share it with
friends and family and that you are
engaging in the battle of ideas
yourselves really makes me putting
myself out there worthwhile you can say
oh somebody said something mean on
Twitter or something said they mean on
Facebook but it's not the same thing as
somebody coming to your doorstep with
weapons saying we're going to kill you
because you're not us there has to be
something for me to be actually bisexual
and also Muslim there's has to be a
place for me we don't have a right to
free speech the way you do in America
it's not enshrined in our Constitution
I'm honored to have such an incredible
fan base that is not only connecting
with me but with each other as well I
don't want to get too much in the
comments section go I'll stay right wait
it's too late for that you maybe you
could host the show for me sometime if I
go on vacation what do you think ladies
clearly you guys all recognize that
we're in this together and that talking
about the important issues honestly is
the only way to move forward as part of
the human right some of us the redneck
sometimes left blow [ __ ] up all right
that did not make us all racist people
tend to use the benefits it is the
status but it's a bit clinging to the
defined
rather than just being something the
past but happen to yourself a little bit
when I what I've been taught to be
through the lens of my life which
doesn't make sense anymore the
second-ever Reuben report ban show is
here let's roll
[Music]
[Music]